at this hour the fda advisory board is
reviewing the pfizer biontech vaccine
and if approved the first shots of that
vaccine
could come just hours from now meanwhile
an article in new york magazine this
week
with the headline we had the vaccine the
whole time
dr peter hotez is a professor and dean
of the national school of tropical
medicine
at baylor also co-director of texas
children's hospital center for vaccine
development
dr hotez always good to talk to you
thanks for being here what were we
supposed to make
of that headline when we saw it how
could there possibly have been a vaccine
for this that already existed well what
happened sandra was
in 2003 the first sars emerged so the
other name for coven 19 is sars2
the first stars emerged out of southern
china in 2003 spread to toronto
and that set off a big u.s government
program under the bush administration
uh to uh and through the nih to support
vaccines
for coronaviruses and we were the
beneficiary of that we
we started making vaccines against the
spike protein as did other groups and
that was really important because it
showed that the spike protein is the
weak link in this virus
and that's how all the current cova 19
vaccines operate so
and and the important point here is that
when many people think that this was a
rushed program it was not it's actually
a program
17 years in the making uh starting back
in 2003.
well it's really information good
information to have right uh
dr hotez in massachusetts the new york
magazine
reports the moderna vaccine design took
all of
one weekend it was completed before
china had even acknowledged that the
disease could be transmitted from human
to human by the time the first american
death was announced a month later
the vaccine had already been
manufactured and shipped to the national
institutes of health
for the beginning of its phase one
clinical trial why were
we told this then because otherwise we
are all in part of the
the public worry about taking the
vaccine is how fast this has gone
compared to other
vaccine approvals so wouldn't this be
good information to put out publicly
that this was
already in the works i think
i think the situation there was because
the rna technology is a brand new
technology it's never resulted in a
licensed vaccine before
people didn't want to over promise or
raise false expectations because we
didn't know
how well that was going to turn out into
a vaccine i think a lot of us were
surprised that it's giving 95 percent
uh protection so the whole point of
operation warp speed
was to create a portfolio to use some
cutting edge new technologies like the
rna vaccines and
and the nih supported our vaccine which
is a recombinant protein vaccine that's
the technology has been around 40 years
and now we're scaling up production of
that in india and the other piece to
this is
we don't know how durable the protection
is going to be for that rna vaccine is
it going to last three months three
years 30 years so that's the wisdom of
that operation warp speed program
create a portfolio so we can get as wide
as many shots on goal as we can
well that public approval hearing is
happening right now with those key
experts weighing in on the pfizer
vaccine we hope the green light comes
soon
dr hotez thank you thank you sandra